Speaker 1: Now, someone whose fundraising has
been supercharged over the last couple of weeks is
Donald Trump. Donald Trump's campaign grifting and
Sorry, sorry, sorry. Fundraising has really been
supercharged by his arrest, although I don't think
that tells us anything about what this does. Forum
in a potential general election matchup. And my
opinion is that the arrest is very bad for Trump.
Politico is reporting Indictment Turbo Charges
Trump's Fundraising. The former president's two
political entities brought in 18.8 million during
the first quarter of this year. Now, of course,
that predates the arrest. But the article reads
Trump raised a combined 18.8 million in the
first quarter. But the campaign says and again,
remember, until they make the FEC filing, the
fact that they say they've raised this much money
is has not been proven. But let's give them the
benefit of the doubt, even though they lie all the
time and say we believe them. They say that they
were able to raise $15.4 million in just two weeks
after charges were filed against Trump, which is a
suggestion that Trump is growing his fundraising
base. And it says nearly a quarter of those who
contributed to Trump during that two week period
after the arrest had never given to Trump before.
I remain convinced that the arrest is good for
Trump in the primary and not good for Trump in the
general election. I believe, and it seems clear
from the data from the claims, we'll get the data
at the end of the quarter. But it seems clear
that when you see, wow, accelerated fundraising
for Trump after the arrest and also a quarter
of the donors never donated to Trump before,
it certainly is feasible to believe from that
that there are existing Republicans and likely
Trump supporters who just never donated
before, maybe because they couldn't afford to,
maybe because they can't really afford to now
and still shouldn't be donating to Trump, who,
after all, is a billionaire. Why does Trump need
to fundraise if he's a billionaire? And the whole
thing was, I don't need anybody's money. I can
finance my own campaign. Okay, put that aside.
I don't doubt that the counter-narrative
and the propaganda that Trump and others are
spreading about the arrest is helping
Trump raise money from MAGA types.
And I don't doubt that this may even help Trump's
polling, which we will be looking at on tomorrow's
program in the primary. But as far as the general
election goes, if Trump is indeed the nominee,
I don't think this gets him a single additional
vote. I don't see any way that it does. The folks
who are actually connected to reality and look at
things in a sane and sober way are overwhelmingly
going to see Trump as a chaotic and beleaguered
candidate because of the arrest. So I'm with many
on the right who have been saying this seals
Trump's primary victory. I don't disagree that
that's an accurate interpretation of what is
going on. I don't think this is good for Trump
in the general. And of course, I'm making a
prediction and we will have to wait and see.